I'm talking to mr.
Peter meacham who worked on
the sydney harbour bridge as
a rigger was it was the reason you get.
What part of the bridge did you work on.
Well what on the pile and and. Were i
put in the stage stage and not for the
for the cleaners and one thing clean and
on the pile and not first of all i was on
there on the railway part but not in the
sleepers. But i don't buy that going over
there and here he indeed was born in london.
And now when i didn't know greece i
don't know. So he called me you know
like you know and you know actually to
go after him. I didn't get
a lot of what they were not so how did
you get the job on the other part of the
bridge. Well when our church and i
cross the bridge. Jimmy come by come
along you know i see what's going on here
is that it's just. Yeah i said economy
has got to come. But you know it's like
every other guys would bring it on the
bridge. So it's actually. Right. And
yet we can't give it passed and he said
look we set out and he said i'll take the
area for
a recovery so. And so i work
then naturally i was in
the end and you have to go and see muir
first. Did you have to go and see mr.
Muir to take on i know it. Tell me if you
go along with i mean i think there are
n clean and future. You know.
And what was your job. Mainly
know well but not risk governance for the
for the concrete concrete and put in
there but now for the men it was but no
stone masons. You know in australia in the
stone. Do you remember how many stone
masons they were working at this was
a view but. Can get dissection.
There you know six year old
when we were reckoned. So that be three
masons and three three labourers with it i
think the labourers was a different
department yes but i think it was
a stormy scotch tell us that there
were two members of the fallen so most
yeah ok. Yeah yeah he did you
know he led the parade i understand
on the on the opening of the have
a ridge on the for the bridge workers might
have come but you know when the bridge
of stop is again and he needs
a little bundle at the funeral. Like
a cross and they think that is buried
over and know them cemeteries. You know
. But. She rumoured to be campbell's
accident. He remembers how
jimmy kimmel die do you. Yes yes i remember
that well you never forget we were
stunned and we were going to work in the
guy ropes and jimmy was saying you know
what you gave
a direction which won it tight. What
was shipped and their power. So this
is the polls that were carrying the staging
for the cleaners the pylon cleaners. As
they pile in cleaners had finished. I'm
not part and we were taking the scarf on
their own and and the outriggers
as well i don't know when
a shift in the power you know we had
just kept it going as well you see
this time he was saying you know
i listen so i mean you go ropes.
Puffer when you come up and
shifted that pole just
a german was struggling to get to the other
side through them up and down and down
and alongside the pilot and
although we don't yet up
a line in the pile and
that he don't think it.
And his head hit the the lighting up
a big part as it hit the lighting on the
way down to it. And yeah yeah yeah that
knee injury was a big big star. You
know and then sleep was a part of
a sleeper but about nine inches apart
that jimmy went right through there right
through to the center of the pile and
down underneath that weren't there but
everybody everybody and his
body was broken and. Then.
The bridge was stop everyone bridge stop.
That route that blood be in and you know
pile and he wanted volunteers to go and
bush and chairs that was what i think was
left was the bush and yes they don't know
and so they're no book and i went over
and bush i shared a room
in a bush and here it was
a government or an apartment where the
blood was either way been there forever.
Was older and think about it. And the
joke like i said the procession of this
funeral that the yet at the funeral. I
suppose we were but oh well over 200 out
of marched past the bridge. I mean i and
passed through the piling it up. I suppose.
And it was led by the pope behind and
he was pretty and he was
a major major i thought that we. He was
older all the time but the pilings you know
about. They went to the northern
cemeteries and that's right. It is i don't
know whether we have done it. Relations out
or not. And this country but it didn't
come from whatever you know do you member
any other accidents while you work you
know the only other activity we had was
wonder why we're old and son issues you
know forever and stop and you know the
thing was when we were daughter and. Just
played and bought your nails and you know.
That's all that thing i could think of
what were you doing before you.
You got on the bridge. I was
a sleeper car in the bush column butting
a political column but you know it's like
dempsey and. I really come down just for
a trip to see that my other
brother. You know. Trust me i did
have a look at the bread you get
and. You know i went door to have
a look. I don't know. Do you know i'd
like to work now. So you know from
a job. I think you become but i think it
is not you become well but they all get
him you're here to discuss i went
to you know you know stick together
. I said what of a job he says
what do you do i said. I'm
a fat no really. I'm you know
a different day sleepers on that real
realtors up here he said oh he says i don't
think that you know four years later but
just leave your name but i dress. You know
loved by the time you know so i get whenever
i dress i do expect to get you know
you know. What i'm not making is
a telegram wait not only. Start
the next more funny stuff.
Told our two brothers she crashed and
you know and i said to the bride i got
a job i said i got the bridge.
I think you were there.
You know she put on your bridge got such
a because you just got
it. You got it. No need
a job in the liberal free weekly are
either job to clean and on the pile and.
When you finish cleaning the pylons were
you laid off or did you get further work.
You know there was so that
everybody was led off i think what
i was and the last ten it was but it
paid off. Well at the last one as
a matter of fact. That before the bridge
was open or after that was before
but
a few days before the bridge or. We
were there on opening day. You get it
right. We're going to see the
rest of the follow and they were
celebrating the law. We didn't take it but
you know. And we we've got the bridge
result that i walked across. I got no part
a lot harder to come across as i said yes
that night. So you know it's such books
as you said there are no i'm just going
to see something my mates and see you for
the absolute but i think we already had
a beat up you know. Nothing and
where did you get any work
after the bridge straight away or not you
know you might have started i wouldn't go
running. Well if you love
a saved up. But i didn't last long
because everyone was there all. Sorry.
Would you call and you get
a cheap rate. You know that's got people
running what it was actually it was at
like customers and some of the rolled up
like i said they couldn't buy you so what
was
a good ask you. Did you get on the
dole then. You know about the fact. I
got job and i saw a hole and
so. I got a job down there as
a man so that. Labor. You know the
labor up to the bottom because
i was there for about twelve months
and that's what well i guess
a beer bottle neck and i went and
told the boss. I think a job was
a bomb maker. He said i said you've got
you've got the trade i said yeah i did say
before you know i'm here but i said.
I lost it when i come up here.
So. I said i might have played out
a loss that when i got it. You know i mean
it wouldn't let me start again. So it's
really 1921 and. So i got
one don't think you know and i told them
the circumstances and of course that
scotchman do not do that
and i do if they ask. Well
where i worked and what we have for who
would support us isn't everything. Told
them. Look we will send you word
give it. It's then i think and
partner. Sent me word and i
could join the union. C.
. So i told i invite and told them i was
and you know and i said. I've got over
a garden and a job i said
i stop here and i get
a job. I was there now holland's hour for
a bit. I suppose they're from. But
free three years. They want to
make their form and i
said no i don't think so. And they're
a brother in my you know he was here and
they had partners here come back for my
one part and i told them i'd take them
off the furnace and they would say.
You know i guess you could go under siege
garden and garden. I don't know you never
remember. Well i'd like
you to tell us about god
. That has the pride and she
had any funny stuff. You got
a job. No war is
a better best thing ever. You don't. Yeah.
You remember garden yourself do you.
Yeah you know. He done
time he revealed and i
was
a good man. Yes i think you know
someone better like me because i wish
to be too strong and i think
you know. Well there was
a spurious rumour on the bridge and i'd
like you to lay it if you can. It was said
freely around on the bridge that if there
was any trouble there was likely to be
a strike or anything any lawrenson is the
flow and director of construction would
run down to garden and get trying to get
him to fix it go. Well i wouldn't know
about that like you know. But i think the
joke was. Don't think everything you know
directly was
a straight job that it be easier if i
want to know whether he was running.
Because anyone could go in and get by
over and going to tell the public anger i
guess because everyone
was just falling for
a chance to get his bearings he was
straight myself but some of the engineers i
reckon that he was the engineer. Well i
said what they were saying you know it was
they said to me it was freely rumored
that he was in earnest pocket
. But again that's
a rumor you know they wouldn't say he was
they would say that you know the world is
going around so i just just since you
since you know you think it's out of the
question. Well you know. I don't know if
he's his life. You know i don't think
it would be. I think if you get name right
where you get the same rumors what's
going on. Just you know it's
a labor says it seems when you get
a job over and going to be sent away for
a job of relating to china. Some
of them places actually make
a split between knowing freighter. Well
that's what they do and that's what they do
in the day and the liver. They both parties
do. As far as any is lawrence ennis is
concerned the doorman long's director of
construction. Why he was interested well
john garden with another scott and it
was a scott. But there was a number of
a couple of demarkation disputes between
the painters and the iron workers and
garden was chairman of the disputes committee
at the straits all wet and when was
this is in between 1930 and thirty
to. While it was finally died out
in one hundred thirty one thirty two
year early 12:30 to where it was after
nineteen terry to you when i went over
and i don't know. I sent arrived at
nineteen terrified because i sent them
down from what i was work and i'm so homes
they know their way from
home so i don't their ships.
You know you were never out of out of
work at all and really. Well i was very
much. I know any time i was our i
guess when bush and i get jobs there.
How long we were actually working on the
bridge both fitting the sleepers and on
the pylon. To land the sleepers.
I tried it out of everyone's
death row and i get so.
I've got to go back
to sleep again. But. Meet and
get me campbell and yeah
i get no john i said well they'll stick out
of her. But yeah regiment camp is there
anything more than anything that stands out
in your mind when you were here on the
bridge. Did you ever go up the
top of the steelworks and stop
a city at what seal where i was and stop
us to go. You know in the pilot your still
. I mean on the arch store and
. $2 piece half hour did
$2 piece like around us
a large store and everyone
that was there. I don't have
a coin and they cut it to
one half on the last of it
and kept the other. Well become
a factor. Were you up there were you in
that picture of the last time we put in i
was standing on the top you could only see
my legs. Because all they had to be an
area. Yeah. Also at the top there was
gordon stuckey and one of the engineers and
a couple of the other ones as well. What
you need was how i felt as i see them down
the bottom there bradfield it is.
I don't know and they want to
go and do you remember where the photographer
was when that photograph was being
taken. I don't know i don't know when they
are drug free all the time because we
had
a clean slate to get their money
and you know and then i was waved
away you know all. No hopers
right away. Everyone. Just
like to see that story. You know and
those you remember that was anything else.
Outstanding. You remember while you were
on the bridge. You know you know much
more i can tell you for the record mr.
Nation where were you born in scotland
sporran blush. I mean what do you
when nineteen hundred and one. So
give us permission.